[Music]
he was staring directly at me
I stole a glance while turning my head
to see bloodshot eyes staring back at me
hello and welcome to all daint a
creepypasta or stories cooked to
perfection with a splash of red sauce my
name is Susie and I will be your server
in this episode I know it's been a while
since the last one and I am going to try
to put these out more often by doing
some shorter episodes from time to time
this is a story I wrote to call the bus
creep let's dig right in I offered to
help my friend move apartments last
night she had rented a u-haul so I
decided to take the bus to her house so
I didn't have to worry about parking
that evening after work I went to the
bus stop near my apartment
the bus was mostly empty that were maybe
eight to ten passengers on board I took
one of the sideways seats near the front
most of the passengers were near the
front since there were plenty of open
seats there was one guy sitting in the
dark in the back of the bus who I
noticed when I first sat down I didn't
think much of it as you can pretty much
count on there being at least one junkie
on every bus ride I usually just try to
ignore it which I did until I heard the
guy get up and walked to the front of
the bus only instead of getting off he
stopped right in front of me and sat
down in the seats directly across my
first inclination is to not make eye
contact but I didn't have to look him in
the eye to realize he was staring
directly at me I stole a glance while
turning my head to see bloodshot eyes
staring back at me he had on one of
those long rim hats like you'd see on a
pilgrim at Thanksgiving with two long
black ponytails coming down over the
shoulders he had a short black trench
coat and black pants but his skin was
pale and rough looking like white
sandpaper his messy facial hair almost
constituted a beard but maybe what
bothered me most was his clenched teeth
I couldn't tell if he was really excited
about something or if the sight of my
face made him furious without reason I
decided I wasn't gonna wait to find out
I got up and moved seats he turned his
head and continued to stare so I just
got on my phone and tried to block him
out this worked for about five minutes
until the guy got up again and moved
into the seat across the aisle from me
okay now this was starting to make me
nervous my stop was coming soon and I
was faced with the predicament chances
are he wasn't going to follow me off the
bus but if he did I'd be alone and
relatively defenseless but if I stayed
on the bus I felt like this dude might
be on the verge of snapping after
considering for another minute I decided
I'd stand up unexpectedly and walk fast
to get off the bus hopefully he'd be
left behind if he even attempted to
follow my heart rate increased as we got
close to my stop but I tried to make it
look like I'd be settled
a while when my stop was called I waited
then I hopped up exited the bus and fast
walked away
I quickly heard the bus door closed
behind me I looked back thinking I'd be
alone but what I saw was the creep
standing there as the bus pulled away is
yellowing teeth glowing in the moonlight
it's that same maddening stare plastered
on his face there was only one thing to
do now speed walk I wasn't gonna run
unless he actually did something
threatening I also gave my friend a call
hey I'm here I lied
can you meet me at the gate as I walked
I made an effort not to make it obvious
that I kept looking back I kept up the
fast pace when I got to the first corner
I snuck a look back over my shoulder the
dude was right on me if anything he was
actually closer than he was before he
was still walking but breathing heavily
to keep up I picked up my pace I J
walked to the next intersection to
prevent him from getting any closer and
he followed nearly getting hit by a car
to do so now I was getting scared I
moved into a jog I was basically jogging
at this point anyway I heard his keys
jingle behind me signaling that he too
had started running I saw my friend
waiting at the gate ahead of me I
motioned her to go inside she got it I
ran through the gate and she swung a
shot behind me just before that haunting
face came up to the gate and stared
through the bars not knowing if he tried
to hop the fence I assured her inside
after explaining that night's events to
this point I was relieved to find out
the garage is connected to her building
and we wouldn't have to go outside to
load the van there was one point where I
thought I saw the man's face again
inside the building the door between the
hallway downstairs and the garage is
made of glass and it's someone swung it
open ahead of us I could have sworn I'd
seen the man from the bus in the
reflection causing me to freeze up in
the middle of the hall
however when we actually looked in the
parking garage it was completely empty
at the time it was easy to chalk up to
my paranoia just me jumping at shadows
but what happened later that night has
sort of thrown that into question it
took a couple of hours to fill up with
you all
by the time we pulled out it was getting
pretty late I sat in the front passenger
seat as she drove she used her clicker
to open the sliding iron gates no sign
of anyone on the street as we pulled out
I looked left and right down the
sidewalk thankfully the street seemed
empty perhaps the guy had gone home the
rest of the night went pretty smoothly
we unloaded the boxes at her new place
celebrated the completion of the move
with a glass of wine and I was on my way
my friend offered me a ride home I
wanted to take it but knowing that they
charge by the mile for you hauls and
knowing that we were nowhere near were
the incident with the bus creep had
taken place I opted to take the bus
again
we were actually closer to where I live
now so I didn't mind and so I was on my
way I'll admit the idea of that man
stare hadn't left my mind as I walked
alone to the bus stop but logically I
didn't expect to see anything and I
didn't run into anyone on the way to the
bus stop when I boarded the bus I made
sure there were no shady-looking
characters hiding in the back and once
again took one of the sideways facing
seats near the front
that's when maybe the most haunting part
of any of this became a reality looking
at the window I saw the same man from
before staring at me from beside the bus
standing right at the bus stop where I'd
been standing moments before I have no
idea how he could have tracked me from
her old apartments to her new apartment
and now to the bus stop miles away from
where this all started it seemed like
slow motion while the bus driver closed
the doors and the man made no attempt to
board his trenchcoat blowing in the wind
as he stared me all the way out of sight
that was the last time I saw the bus
creep in person since then I've woken up
three times tonight each time his face
was piercing into my nightmares I don't
think I'll be taking the bus tomorrow
[Music]
thanks for listening - Ahnold ain't a
creepypasta
your total today comes out to one dollar
and seventy five cents but if you like
this video right now I'll waive that fee
and give you everything you just listen
to absolutely free remember to subscribe
to see the world some new Horrors every
week bring that that Bell for
notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we survive